military officials told the New York
Times and the most resolved UFO cases
can be attributed to foreign spies or
Airborne trash so there's trash in the
sky speeding along at the speed of sound
changing directions mid-flight where's
this trash coming from is it trash that
the aliens have thrown out of their UFOs
in May during congress's first public
UFO Hearing in more than 50 years
Pentagon officials testified that a
video with mysterious glowing green
triangles actually displayed drones that
were shot through night vision lenses in
another video referred to as go fast an
unknown object appear to move at
incredible speed military officials
later debunked the video as an illusion
created by the angle of observation
against water oh come on so where's the
trash part are they going to even
explain in this article how trash could
what is what's what is the trash doing
40 000 feet in the air and how is it
moving that way and what kind of trash
is this are these plastic straws has the
plastic straw problem gotten that bad
that now they're they're whizzing
through the sky too